joining us now with all this breaking
news we have ohio congressman jim jordan
remember jim jordan
and guys like matt gates and and and
certainly mark meadows and
john ratcliffe i don't want to miss
anybody have
behind closed doors as congressman doug
collins revealed
uh you are asking the right questions at
the right time
now that we have these 302s that offer
all of this confirmation all that you're
hearing tonight congressman
we seem to have two separate paths that
were used for
spying again the 99 of the fbi
great people the premier law enforcement
agency in the world
on our intelligence side the premier
intelligence agencies in the world
but at the highest levels it seems that
both we had
outsourcing of tactics and means of
spying on americans that would be
illegal they did it purposely to
seemingly to circumvent american laws
and on the other side of course we have
the dirty dossier then we have a guy
that's fired for lying and leaking
and he's got a conduit and the conduit
is bruce ohr whose wife by the way
helped build the dirty russian dossier
for hillary clinton infusion gps
as you read this fill in the blanks so
so the audience here can understand this
completely no that last point i think is
important why do you terminate your
direct relationship with christopher
steele and then encourage a top justice
department official
to keep meeting with him and then coming
and briefing you about each of those
meeting in each of those
conversations so that's point number one
it seems to me you're trying to hide
some or trying to camouflage something
when you do that second why do you do
302s you do 302's because you're out to
get someone
and we know they weren't out to get
bruce or they're out to get someone else
who are they out to get
the president of the united states look
at the 12 302s and notice the dates
there's three bursts there's the burst
right after the election
there's the burst right after the
inauguration and then there's the ones
in may
right after the special counsel is named
so that this all just shows
they were out to go after the president
of the united states and never forget
the guy who was leading the
investigation said clinton should win
100 million to zero
don't worry lisa we'll stop trump we got
an insurance policy
so that's the key takeaway and you've
been on this for a couple years
but when you now put this all together
it seems pretty clear what they were up
to